so today we're talking about warzone
coming to your phone and how master
chief wanted to be link sorta
according to industry insider tom
henderson who also dropped details on a
rumored expansion of assassin's creed
valhalla this week activision is
planning to release a mobile version of
call of duty warzone in 2022 this week
saw more evidence uncovered when warzone
mobile was added to playtest cloud a
database that provides play testing
services for mobile game studios
interestingly playtest cloud says that
the game listing has been removed from
its database because it hasn't been
confirmed to exist yet and the company
says it doesn't have any information
about upcoming titles back in august
activision officially confirmed that it
had formed a new studio by the name of
solid state to develop a new entry in
the call of duty series however it
wasn't mentioned to be a war zone
project currently call of duty mobile
has a battle royale mode available
within it but the game is a broader
slice of multiplayer influenced by the
mainline series
so are you interested in a mobile
warzone or is cod mobile's current
offering more than enough for you let me
know in the comments down below
and now let's move on to halo infinite
and how it once had an open world like
breath of the wild bloomberg reports 343
began planning what would be halo
infinite not long after halo 5 guardians
was released in 2015. the studio
considered different ideas before
settling on a plan to make halo into an
open world game but ran into development
issues due to its development suite
known as faber which was old and
challenging to use in summer 2019 this
came to a head and 343 elected to cut
nearly two-thirds of what was planned
for halo infinite the report says quote
eventually the game's open world was cut
back from a vast zelda-like experience
into something far smaller so i know
halo's campaign is out today but have
you played it yet and do you wish it was
bigger let me know
and now for my oh my god just make gta 6
already segment
grand theft auto online is expanding in
a big way this month with the launch of
a new gta online story featuring
franklin and dr dre the expansion is
called the contract and it releases on
december 15th the story takes place
years after franklin michael and trevor
completed a daring heist of the union
depository in the main campaign in the
time since then franklin has opened a
new company called f clinton and partner
it's described as a quote celebrity
solutions agency and caters to the elite
of vinewood and in the story you have to
find hip-hop legend dr dre's phone the
device contains new unreleased music
from dre and could be the big break that
franklin's company needs
so why this isn't just single player dlc
i don't know but regardless i hope all
of you online players really enjoy it
and let me know in the comments how much
real life money you've spent in gta
online we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]